queremos derivar con respecto a x la
integral de x a 3 de la raíz cuadrada
del valor absoluto de coseno de t dt
esta es una pregunta totalmente válida
verdad porque este límite inferior
depende de x e incluso parece ser que
podemos aplicar el teorema fundamental
del cálculo sin embargo aquí la x está
en el límite inferior y no en el límite
superior como nos lo pide el teorema
fundamental cómo le podemos hacer para
resolver esta dificultad o para llegar a
algo que sí sabemos pues ve la idea
clave está en pensar qué sucede cuando
intercambiamos los límites de
integración ya hemos pensado un poquito
en eso pero déjame hacer un pequeño
paréntesis para recordarlo entonces
tomemos digamos la integral la integral
es que un poco feo la integral de a a b
de fcc ft dt apuesta integral esta
integral sabemos que es igual a efe tv -
efe - f de a donde f mayúscula es la
anti derivada de efe minúscula verdad
esto fue un corolario al teorema
fundamental del cálculo o bien le
podemos llamar
el teorema fundamental parte 2 o bien el
segundo problema fundamental de cálculo
bueno no importa el nombre la cosa es
que así evaluamos las integrales
definidas verdad le ponemos los límites
de integración en la anti derivada y lo
restamos entonces después vamos a ver
qué sucede si multiplico aquí por menos
si hago eso hay que multiplicar acá por
menos y acá también y nos quedaría que
menos menos la integral de a a b de fcc
de ft dt es igual a menos toda esta cosa
de acá - efe - efe y pues distribuyendo
este signo menos nos queda menos efe db
más efe de a así que déjame poner el f
de a positivo nos quedaría de a efe
mayúscula - efe mayúscula de b y mira
esto está padre ahora otra vez por el
teorema y fundamental del cálculo bueno
por el corolario o por el segundo
teorema fundamental del cálculo ahora
tenemos esa mayúscula
- efe mayúscula de modo que es la
integral de
efe dt de ft vete a esto está súper
padre verdad entonces para intercambiar
los límites de integración basta
multiplicar por un signo negativo o bien
también lo podemos decir al revés es
verdad si una integral la multiplicamos
por menos es lo mismo que intercambiar
sus límites de integración bueno ya con
esta idea vamos a regresar al problema
original y entonces lo que queremos es
encontrar la derivada con respecto a x
la derivada con respecto a x de menos lo
voy a poner así de menos la integral de
3x de la raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada
del valor absoluto de coseno de tdt
y ahí está
y bueno como le hacemos para resolver
esto pues esto ya está más o menos fácil
bueno ya llega algo que ya sabemos hacer
este menos lo podemos sacar nos queda la
derivada con respecto a x de la integral
de 3x de la raíz cuadrada bueno de eso
mismo verdad ya para que lo digo más
debía haberlo copiado y pegado a tan
gente no coseno dt
jose no de tdt ok y bueno ya nada más le
llevamos aquí utilizando el teorema
fundamental entonces nos quedaría menos
y aquí la función es la de adentro nada
más que ésta ya no la tenemos que
evaluar entre sí no tenemos que
evaluarla en el extremo superior que es
x nos queda menos la raíz cuadrada del
valor absoluto del coseno de x y listo